hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse
glad to be back it's been a while and
today we're going to work on our react
native browser editor which we started
working on a while ago and it's been
like four or five months so just to give
a give an intro to the show and the
project since there's it's been a long
time and there's probably a lot of
people that are new in this in this
stream what I'm trying to do is work on
a real project and I don't rehearse
beforehand so there's gonna be mistakes
but that's the point is just to show you
what it's really like to work on
something to make mistakes and to to
work through those mistakes so the
format is I will do 25 minutes where I
code and I don't really look at the live
chat very much and then I'll take a
five-minute break
I'll look at the live chat and I'll
answer questions and usually do like
maybe two sessions like that then at the
end I'll look at the live chat and try
to answer as many questions as I can
so if you have questions just be patient
I'll get to them the recording of this
live stream is available just a few
minutes after the live stream ends so if
you have a question but you can't wait
for the answer then check out the
recording and I'll probably answer your
question at some point during the stream
feel free to ask ask questions if you're
a beginner you know don't worry about
you know asking questions about even
just really basic stuff that's totally
fun try to keep the live chat positive
so you know I will if there's any like
harassment or negative stuff or anything
like that
I'll just block you from the chat so I
think that's it in terms of introduction
for the stream but in terms of the
project what I'm trying to do is I want
to get for this demo right we're just
using create react app to make a little
proof of concepts so that we can edit
react native code in a browser and have
it display right there in the browser so
very similar to what you would see on
free code camp org where you know you
have like the split screen and you can
type in HTML and JavaScript and then
have the result appear that's what we
want but we wanted to do we wanted to
happen with react native code
so
I just happened to look over the stream
so it says can you say the starting and
end timing the streams usually end up
being like around an hour sometimes a
little bit more than an hour so that's
what I'm that's what I'm usually going
for and I see a ton of people saying hi
so hey everybody thanks for watching and
I am going to get started now so I'm
gonna bring up a hold or a timer on my
other screen here
and I wanted to get started by upgrading
packages right so this is the the same
project that we left off on months ago
I've done nothing to it right so I want
the stream to be as realistic as
possible sometimes this happens you come
back to an old project and I'm coming
back to this project after a long time
and I want to update the packages right
for whatever reason it won't run so I
did try to run it just a few minutes ago
and I'm not even a mess with that error
because I know that all my packages are
at least you know a few months out of
date so I want to go through how to how
to do an upgrade like like a math
upgrade here so I'm gonna do I'm using
yarn instead of NPM okay so that's just
a an alternative package manager for
JavaScript packages for NPM packages so
we can do yarn upgrade and then I'm
gonna give it the flag latest actually
let me do upgrade interactive
the latest I believe that's the that's
the command let's see
yep that's it all right so
I'm gonna make this bigger and hopefully
the fonts big enough I don't know that I
could go much bigger and still display
things on the screen so this is what
happens when you type in when you do
yarn upgrade interactive it gives you a
little display here that tells you what
packages you're using that are out of
date and how out-of-date it is right so
it'll say like this is where you're at
this way you need to go right and it
gives and it looks like all of the stuff
it's showing me up to the top here is
red now there there is more right so as
I scroll down to keep showing me more so
you can see a lot of our stuff is it's
out of date Wow
we're almost all into the end of the red
here right Wow I think it just keeps
keep scrolling through so we're not we
don't have an endless list list of
packages it just keep starting back at
the beginning so ya see it just keeps
rolling but let's uh let's start
somewhere and see what we actually want
to update and in reality I I really want
to try to update everything and then see
what happens since this is still like a
work in progress I'm okay with breaking
it right we were using it so we can
always just roll it right back so
I can just run now that we've seen it
instead of going through and like
picking one by one what I want
let's see I think I'm gonna get out of
this I'm gonna ctrl C to get out of it
and then let's go with
let's go Jana upgrade and I'm gonna get
rid of the interactive I'm just gonna do
upgrade and then I'm gonna say latest
and this should do all the upgrading
without giving us an option of what to
upgrade its just gonna upgrade
everything to the latest it this is
gonna take probably a minute or two
which is fine because it's gonna give me
a chance to check the live chat for a
little bit now I kind of expect that
things aren't gonna work when we do this
because there's so many breaking changes
and that's okay I just now is the time
to try to update you know you don't want
to keep your packages like so out of
date all the time right ideally we would
have been working on this and this this
whole time in the past four or five
months and when a package went out of
date we would have updated it but that
didn't happen so we're gonna try this
we're gonna see what errors we get and
my plan is if we get if the errors are
just so crazy that it's gonna take
forever then we will just start a new
project and basically copy and paste
what we need to over since we didn't get
that far into this project that's great
wow that was fast
I expected that to take longer but that
seemed to be kind of a hit worked but
okay and our package.json should be
updated so let's check some of these
dependencies like alright so or react
dependency yeah
wow that is jetsam the latest
okay all right so that did work so let's
just shower run it
if this actually runs I'm gonna be like
really surprised all right so it didn't
it didn't run okay
and to say
all right well now we got an error we
know at least somewhere to start
just
chicken this uh the live Chad just for a
second okay all right so let's check
this out in our components workspace Jas
I am using Visual Studio code as my my
code editor workspace space Jas
getting an error
[Music]
111
okay so this is a seat there's just a
figure just a feature in this one
oh okay so this is just a config issue
so
and see if it tells us that the
experimental decorators option
do we have a config
I don't think I have a config for my
linter right now
that was should be
yeah Babel should be handling this
okay
so what we've done in this project is we
put in a lot of code from another open
source project and we're trying to adapt
that so this is some of that code from
that other project they're using in
experimental syntax and so that's where
we're getting this this error from so
what I'm thinking now is at first I
thought okay maybe this is just a
linting error meaning like our linter
linters check your code for errors and
if you're using experimental things you
have to tell your linter that like hey
I'm gonna use this experimental stuff I
know it's gonna look like it's broken
but it's not right but now I'm seeing
like maybe - not a saying parsing Eric
maybe I'm not actually transpiring that
so if you want to use an experimental
feature in JavaScript you need to use a
transpiler so usually it's this this
tool called Babel and what Babel does is
it takes your your experimental code and
it transforms it into normal JavaScript
that a browser can handle so if that's
the issue then we need to make sure that
Babel can handle that so I do have
something in babel for their decorators
right that's what I believe that's what
it we word
yeah but for whatever reason this is not
working
so
we'll see
let's look at I guess the first thing to
look at would be the project I want to
see how they set up Babel for the for
the project that I got this code from
you might just be able to copy and paste
from there and and this would work right
so let's do that first so I'm gonna
bring over a browser window actually you
know I think I have I think I have the
project open yep I do
yeah just bring this browser window over
so this is the no that's not it to many
projects
it's weird
but there they sought to search for it
or I could just check the package Jason
are we bringing it
there we go this is the that's the
person that is just doing this just
search for this person on github
there we go
github knew what I wanted okay
so let's check
all right that's it that's the same so
we get the same babel config make this
so bigger
so you've ever config and
let's see
two men each other saying something -
just to use okay let's see let's try it
let's try it out who is so Fred well
let's try it out
you soon if I use it like this
you know legacy linter options and UVs
code settings are no longer being used
for your code formatter
interesting
yeah and I remove them right now
I don't want to deal with that right now
okay
so you change that
it
it looks like
should we get a new era is that it I
believe we did
all right cool so shout out to Fred
because that seemed to at least get us
around like our-our linter is still
complaining but at least we got past the
the air I was afraid that we would have
had like similar usage in a lot of other
places and it would have been a mess but
I guess we don't so that's who we have
do not use import syntax to configure
web pack loaders
let's check this in also
so it has been a while since we imported
this code so it's probably worth
checking out this workspace JS file in
the the repo that we just brought in
Conan's work space in case this has been
updated since the last time yeah it does
it does not look like it's been updated
you can see it's June 5th 2017 right sir
definitely not not updated all right
[Music]
I lost track of where I put my palm with
over time it said there is all right
cool in about five or six minutes I'm
gonna take a break and I'm gonna answer
some questions so you just hang in there
if you got any questions in the chat all
right so let's search for I believe I
did copy and paste the error yet
oh cool it looks like it's just a linter
thing so
interesting okay so yes
so I guess I could just
[Music]
disable that throw line how do I throw
nothing
all right so I'm gonna go to stack
overflow this seems to just be a linting
thing and so I don't remember how to
disable yes lint for a line so yes I see
oh cool
sweets so we should just be able to yes
late yes length disabled line and then
put the name of what the rule that we
want to disable so let's try that out
[Music]
all right let's see if Fitness
that is
all right cool so that that actually did
work so good to know you can disable a
single line in es Lent and just disable
that particular rule
important body reorder to top all right
that's that's easy
so let's go to our index touch a s which
it's kind of weird that I have that in
there and it ever worked
and they just I might have to deal with
this this issue because it keeps popping
up and annoying me
all right we're getting through we're
getting through the airs unexpected use
of history no restricted
you tools
straight
and 60
that's weird
I would not have thought that that would
give
give this air but I guess
and
all right let's see if we just can
disable this line as well yes let's just
say well I already forget what the what
I just typed in the other one was yes
disabled disabled line
is disabled line
yes
I took into the tickets back to that
looks like that the little switch that
we put in here and is still not working
so we're gonna take a little break and
I'm gonna answer some questions and then
when we come back we're gonna go back to
this decorators decorator legacy isn't
currently enabled we're gonna look at
this decorator issue all right so I'm
gonna scroll all the way up to the top
and go down through and try to answer
some questions as many as I can
it looks like I may not have access to
the questions at the top so there's been
a lot of activity in the chat so if you
ask your question like super early like
before the stream started I may not see
it
so this get a question this is can I get
an 8 digit salary after doing this
course
probably not 8 digits is pretty it's a
lot
all right so unconscious a very beginner
in react.js want to learn very
enthusiastic about the course thanks
hunka and I just want to clarify so this
this live stream is not exactly a course
right so this is it's it's not meant to
be a tutorial that where I'll take you
through like from beginning to end and
you'll learn concepts and things like
that this is a look into like a real
project it's a lot of troubleshooting
right like we like we have right now is
you know we're trying something that you
would normally have to do right like
projects get out of date you have to
update packages this is what happens
when you update packages when you wait
too long you try to update packages you
get errors the errors are in code that I
didn't write myself right which is this
happens like really it you know you come
into a project you inherit someone
else's code right so the idea of the
stream is to try to be as close as
possible to a real developer experience
right because that way
there are things that you learn from
just doing that you wouldn't necessarily
learn from a course and that's I think
the value in this in this live stream is
when things don't go right in there
aren't instructions or how to fix it
like what do you do so that's what we're
doing here
so it's it's not exactly a course but
hopefully we'll learn something as we as
we code
okay it looks like there were some
discussions and like some questions are
getting answered like in the chat by
other people so I'm gonna kind of like
scroll past that Abhishek is asking
about what's what's best software or AI
so artificial intelligence and I'm
assuming for different degree so what's
best for a degree software or artificial
intelligence I'm not really sure about
that one I don't know enough about it to
know what what a better degree would be
I mean I do know if like you don't need
a degree to do software work but
probably if you want to be on like the
cutting edge of AI research like in a
university they're probably gonna want
you to have a doctorate degree I'm
assuming I don't know for sure of course
there are companies that are also on the
cutting edge of AI research that you
wouldn't maybe necessarily need to be a
doctor have a Doctorate degree to work
on it
Sode says what programming language
should I start with new to programming
which should I start with really you can
start with anything javascript is an
easy one to start with because it can
run in the browser so
and and you can there's a lot of free
resources for it it's a nice one to
learn it can run client-side and
server-side but realistically if you're
just starting out just to learn the
programming concepts you can start out
with anything and you're gonna learn the
same the same concepts and then switch
to you know whatever you you need to but
if you want to go the route of like free
code camped out Oregon with those
lessons then the first programming
language you learn will be JavaScript
alright cool so my timer my five-minute
timer is up I'm gonna start a new
Pomodoro a session of 25 minutes and
we're gonna get back to the code I'll
come back to the questions looks like
there's a ton of questions which is
awesome so but I'll come back to those
questions after after this next coding
session all right so I'm gonna copy and
paste this part
so when I get errors like this how you
probably can't see
let me probably can't see the whole
message here so yeah my face is blocking
out the entire message but basically
when I get an error message
are you I want to try to copy and paste
the part that doesn't have reference to
my project in particular right because
when I search for that nobody's gonna
have that right so so my the name of the
file works based yes I don't want that
and I don't want the like the location
of the error in terms of the the line in
my file right but if there's anything
that seems generic that's what I want to
copy and paste so I'm just seeing a
second what I'm what I've decided to
copy and paste so I'm gonna leave this
linting thing up so I can keep
referencing it because I'm sure I'll
forget the syntax again all right but
I've what I paste it is this decorators
support for experimental syntax
decorators legacy isn't currently
enabled right and hey there's a whole
medium article under that's interesting
I'm gonna open this that is titled the
exact name of the error that we got oh
that's awesome I don't know that I've
ever had that happen before
so let's see what we need to do let's
see how old this is first okay so it's
from this year it's from May 4th so
that's relatively new all right let's do
this
so let me make this bigger so you can
kind of see this but this is great I
can't believe whoever wrote that who
wrote this Patrick so shout out to
Patrick for writing a medium article all
about this error all right so we're
going to install this new babble plugin
and try to use that instead of the other
battle plug-in that we had
so it's possible since so much time has
elapsed that the old that we'll plug in
it just isn't supported anymore maybe
that's that's why we haven't some issues
so we're installing that
and now let's I think we have a Babel
horsey so that's let's use this one
so there there are two different types
of configuration files for babbles so
that's why there's two different ears so
you can have a babble duck config KS and
the syntax is a little different for
each one so or you can have a dot babble
or C so I believe we have a dot babble
RC yep and we do so in our plugins I I'm
guessing I can just get rid of this this
transform decorators legacy and it
doesn't like the the difference in and
the quotation works
there we go what is this incorrect type
of six mush
oh it thinks I'm trying to use types
girls
and I believe it did say in that thing
to restart stride
oh no we still getting the same error
yeah all right let's see so
[Music]
I mean double-check this
shoot
all right the shy
let's try the stackoverflow one
looks like is there no all right so I
don't think they actually selected an
answer that worked but this one let us
have the most votes which this seems
like the same thing the only other thing
I can think of is maybe since we use
create react app it's not picking up
this babel RC file so let's check that
out so create react app is a great tool
to start a react project but it does
limit you a little bit in stuff like
this so in in like anything that has to
do with a custom web pack configs which
we're starting to get into like web pack
stuff here so or at least related to web
pack so let's go
[Music]
so I'm just typing in use dot babble RC
with a with create react app so when I
do any search I usually try to say just
one stuff from the past year because I
don't want out-of-date out-of-date stuff
there we go using custom
let's see what this this is for a
different project but you might have to
use cut okay I wasn't sure if we'd have
to use this or not but it looks like we
might
my fuse customized create react app let
me make sure I'm not already using it
where's a package a song
yeah all right so let's do that this is
actually this is gonna be fun okay so if
you need to modify your create react app
like your web pack config or your babble
stuff for create react app there's a
plug-in you can use called customize
create react app actually it's
customized CRA
right so we're gonna go to their github
page so that we can see what we need to
add so it does use react app rewired
which from what I understand react app
rewired was like the first way they came
out that you could do stuff like this
but it's now customized create react app
is kind of sorry it's like built on top
of that so that's why we need both so
let's do this
so this potentially could cause problems
with create react app projects only use
it if you really need to use it I've had
success using it on projects it hasn't
like messed up anything before so but
just be aware that you know it can throw
things off alright so now that we have
that in there let me let me double check
to make sure there's we don't need to do
anything else
usage config overrides
all right so we do need a config
overrides file and actually
it doesn't have it I was hoping it would
have they would have something in there
[Music]
so
sorry almost the name is config override
CAS there we go so let's make a config
overrides done GS file
so we're gonna make this just in the
root of our project
configure override cas and i'm gonna
copy and paste
just to get us started
there we go and a lot of this we don't
need like really well you I want to add
this decorators legacy and actually
disabling yes Lin is probably not a bad
idea since we're getting all these es on
airs but that's just in [ __ ] that's
cool don't need that and I don't need
this alright and so now I don't need
these
and all right see if that'll work
I'm gonna manually restart this
yeah
take various legacy
still not working
okay
hmm
under why
while the giddiness
all right so we have
[Music]
and it looks like we have everything
that scene
all right let's go back
let's get rid of that one and this is
okay we haven't looked at this one yet
this is just in general how you use that
well plug ins with create react app so
probably not a bad idea to look over
this just to make sure that we did it
right
UCS on RC East bad boys
we do we want to use our babble or see
okay this might be this might be it
so we don't we're not going to pull this
in directly we want it to use bevel RC
now now it should actually look at her
babble warsi file
oh and I need to change change this haha
alright I can't believe I forgot this
okay so before career act app actually
starts how did I not see this in the
documentation like this is not in here
that's kind of weird okay anyway so
let's check our package.json file here
so we want to run instead of running
winner when we run our scripts instead
of running it through react scripts we
want to run it through react app rewired
and that was that was probably our
issues of stuff this may have actually
worked before the way we had it and now
it so now it will run through react app
rewired so let's see - voiceover februar
see is not the phone you use that warsi
is not to find yep you're correct
these bad boys
[Music]
now it's going to use a new stuff
alright we got a new error sweet so
let's go back to our code our new error
is plug-in preset files are not allowed
to export objects only functions whoa
this is actually a problem in our node
modules that's why
that's pretty crazy because like this
it's a note much all right let's look
this up let's get rid of some windows
while we're at it maybe are we using
you're not using a new version of
[Music]
[Music]
you probably hear my kids in the
background so that's it they're on their
way to school there's a question here it
isn't react native browser just react
yes no it's not so what we're trying to
do is is say that you can type into a
browser window like a like an editor and
in browser editor react native code and
then have that code actually run and
display in the browser right and in a
little like window in the browser right
so we need the code to be converted into
something that the browser can
understand like on the fly in the
browser and it's so it's it's not it's
not running react native so that it can
go in the browser right it's not just
that it's it's actually trying to
convert the react native code on the fly
in the browser the the use case for this
is being able to have online tutorials
online react native tutorials where
someone doesn't have to go through
everything necessary to run react native
on their local machine and they can just
go into the browser and type it in
I type in actual react native code and
then see what the result would be right
[Music]
so you're making you think I know
compiler to JavaScript yeah basically
yeah yeah it's it's like it's gonna be
like an in-browser compiler of react
native to normal JavaScript sorry guy
kind of off track from the coding but
that was a I figure out what I needed to
clarify that otherwise what we're doing
is not gonna make that much sense okay
so
it looks like
that will preset yes 2015 okay so this
is is I believe related to like a new
way that babbles doing it stuff so like
you see that it says at sign babble
right so this is the way we should be
doing it and instead we're doing it this
this older way so we need to switch
things up so instead of like for
instance the set of reactors should be
at babble react you just saw yeah so
that's what we need to do next
right now my timers up though so I'm
gonna answer some questions and in the
answer some questions and then on our
next live stream this is where it will
go so actually if I have time I might
try to sort this out before the next
live stream but otherwise then we'll
kind of just pick up here with switching
over our babble stuff to use the latest
and it looks like the reason we didn't
see this error before is because our
create react app is just completely
bypassing our babble RC so we had it in
here
but if this was never running which I
mean that makes sense so anyway let me
go to the chat and I'm gonna scroll up
to where I left off that I'm gonna try
to get as many questions as I can in so
I may not be able to get to all the
questions cuz I do have to start my my
normal job so I'm a software engineer
and so if I don't get your question you
can always put it in the comments to the
video
and then I can try to answer it later on
okay
so we have a question what is react
alright so react is a JavaScript library
for building apps and so it just it
gives you this it helps mostly with
state management and it gives you an
HTML like syntax called JSX that lets
you kind of mix together HTML what looks
like HTML with JavaScript and create
create apps so that's a super high level
but basically like if you want to make
web apps then react helps you do that
Dragonstone creation says the fan is
noisy can you reduce speed I'm sorry
about that you know what I'm right now
I'm setup in my basement so I believe
the the heater was running so apologies
for that
i i have plans to put up some walls
around my work area and like soundproof
it but hasn't happened yet so i'm hoping
I can get that done soon and then the
noise won't be an issue so I'm sure you
can hear like the garage door shutting
now and you could hear my kids coming
down so not an ideal situation for live
streaming but if I waited for everything
to be ideal then I probably would never
lush
okay a question will you save the stream
yeah the stream the stream does get
recorded and it's available to watch on
the free cook camp Channel
[Music]
dragon some creation says if so many
packages are outdated in the short time
when building a huge project won't it be
a problem yeah it's definitely a problem
so I've actually yesterday at my my job
I went through two of the the apps that
we're building and I upgraded all of the
packages and I do that pretty regularly
because if you wait like we've done here
in this project until you get so many
things outdated you can see there's a
lot of errors that we're working through
so it's much easier to say like okay I'm
gonna go through and you can just set a
time for your project if you really want
to like alright once a month I'm gonna
check or you know whatever its amount of
time you set you can say I'm gonna check
the projects if there are some packages
that are like really like key packages
that you're using you might want to just
say every time there's a new release I'm
gonna read through the release notes see
what what is happening if there were
less packages and probably would have
done that you probably would have read
through the release notes on github and
seen if there were any breaking changes
and then tried to fix those according to
the instructions that the the package
maintainer set so in this case there was
just too much so I thought hey let's
just go for it
see what happens also you know this this
isn't like a critical application or
anything like that so we could afford to
break it okay but yeah and a big app
that's like actually in use you'd want
to stay on top of this and not let your
stuff get out of date
servant says are you coating with expo
not for this particular project but I do
code with Expo pretty much every day
I like Expo if you're not sure what Expo
is it's it's a set of tools I guess that
help you build with react native react
native is a way to use react to build
mobile apps primarily mobile apps you
can note other stuff with it too but the
number one use case is Android and iOS
Anderson Silva says I'm a software
engineer at Google that's awesome I am I
did interview with Google this is Friday
a year ago and I made it all the way to
like when you get on campus and do like
you know I think it's like five
interviews on campus in a day but I
didn't make it past there so maybe one
day I'll interview with them again we'll
see but that's cool I did actually I did
a video about it too so if you want to
if anyways interested in what it's like
to interview at Google you can check it
out so I I think it's on the free code
Kent Channel it's also on my channel so
if you like this stream and want to see
more stuff you can check out my youtube
channel the links in the description
that decorator era okay so I'm not
exactly sure what new version I'm
running on my machine right now but I
don't know that that would matter that
matter for because I think because we're
trying to use it
client-side it wouldn't necessarily
matter server side it definitely would
Louie sees his eunuchs and diamonds are
forever is pretty much true eunuchs is
everywhere
cherry vanilla asked what languages is
JavaScript's
Nick Nick Nick Kunz says can we add
babel RC to normal react projects well I
wish I would have seen that earlier
because that actually was part of our
issue is that you can't just add AB AB
or C to normal
recreate react app projects right you
have to do customized create react that
so good catch on that one
charbel says how will the web editor
compile code that's a great question and
so actually we're using service workers
so like the compiled stuff happens here
in our babel worker je s so it basically
like we're taking what what happens like
on your local machine when you so there
is a there's a package called react
native web which takes react native and
converts it into basically HTML CSS and
javascript that appraiser can use but it
does that right locally on your machine
so we're taking that and using it in a
service worker so that it happens every
time you type in something in your
browser right so like it's it's really
cool but that's basically that's how we
get it to work is like in place of your
local machine we have a service worker
running
Anderson Silva says why are you using a
dark theme github I just I like dark
theme so yeah I have the dark theme get
a thing so it's I'm just using a
tampermonkey script it's if you look up
github dark I think you'll you'll see
like instructions for how to do a github
dark theme I just prefer it especially
when I'm coding like I have the dark
theme on my code editor and to switch to
github like it's just this flash of
bright it when you have the white
background so it's better to have as for
me at least I prefer to have as much
stuff as I can on the dark mode easier
on my eyes
[Music]
Anderson Silva says you don't like Linux
I like Linux
[Music]
oh and in Fred Fred came through with
the syntax to disable esn't disabled
next line so thank you for that I didn't
see it in the comments but that would
have been helpful I need to get back in
the hang of live streaming since it's
been a while of like glancing back and
forth of the comments I'll get there
so there's a lot of discussion about in
the chat so I'm still I'm scrolling
through looking for questions
Auggie says hello Jessie I'm from
Indonesia I love to watch while UCO's
awesome thanks thanks for watching let's
see you have a question wrote ronique
not sure to pronounce that for sure so
if apologies if I'm mispronouncing that
but anyway it says which platform is
easier to deploy from react native or
expo I have two mobile apps I want to
build I am familiar with react and I've
created a simple react native app but
clear hmm unclear which is better I
think
Expo makes it easier to deploy like in
terms of actually deploying to the App
Store to deploy in an update so I would
check out Expo in general when you're
using react native I recommend always
using Expo unless you have some reason
like something you need to do in your
app that you can't do with Expo and even
then you could always start with it and
then eject but there there are so many
Expo handles so much for you that it
just kind of makes it a nicer developer
experience so I definitely recommend
using that for react native
deaf bosses do you have a telegram
channel or group I don't think we have a
telegram I'm not 100% sure like I
definitely don't for the live stream I
don't know if recode camp does this
anybody know free code camp has a
telegram it's possible that we do and I
just don't know about it if I want to be
an effective full-stack developer should
I take a cybersecurity course to be an
effective full-stack developer I don't
think it's necessary to take a
cybersecurity course to be full-stack if
that's what you're into and you want to
like specialize in that that's fine it
definitely wouldn't hurt you but I
wouldn't say it's necessary
Senta says can you please use dart mode
for browser a dark mood for browser
thought I was using dark mode in my
browser I'm not sure Santa could you
elaborate on that question
tomorrow a squid getting a certificate
be better than getting a degree because
I'm in college and a little loss because
of it it depends on what you want to do
Jamal really if you want to do like web
development then you probably you know
don't need a degree you can get and you
don't need a certificate either you just
need a portfolio you need some
experience but different different
aspects of like coding it it just
depends so like it depends on where
you're at what country you're in certain
certain places or certain industries
still prefer a degree so you would
definitely need to I would need more
information let's say to be able to tell
for sure right like can you get a good
job without a without a degree yeah
definitely in in some in some type of
coding but if there's something you
really specifically want to do then it
may be more helpful to get a degree
maybe not
Thomas says do understand what he's
coding I'm new to coding and I have no
clue Thomas don't worry about it like
feel free to ask any questions we did
did we like we just jumped into this
project so it's it's definitely okay to
be a little bit confused like in reality
like this is like I'm a little bit lost
right we're trying to work through bugs
and everything so that's totally
understandable to be a little lost
alright we're just like jumping right
back and doing a project that we haven't
some of you have not seen it all before
I haven't looked at it in four months so
that's a that's a legitimate feeling to
have
see just trying to scroll through and
find actual questions there's a lot a
lot of comments and stuff
Thomas says not a question but just
wanted to say thanks for teaching me a
lot of concepts that I know now your
videos have been very helpful thank you
I appreciate that
boo boo pendra says is there any
relation or similarity between react Jas
and react native yeah definitely so a
lot of the concepts are the same so like
the way you handle state is the same in
react Jas and react native like the
structure of the the JSX syntax is the
same so honestly they're react native
and react in terms of how you develop
things like from the developer
perspective of trying to build something
with them are very very similar so
you're just using components to build
apps the differences are mainly in what
components you can use right so in react
you can use what we call like Dom
primitives so divs spans P tags H H tag
stuff like that you can't use that in
react native so that's that's probably
the biggest difference when you're
developing all right so there are other
tags that come with react native that
you would use in in that place but like
whether you start with react native or
if you start with react switching from
one to the other is not very difficult
Gavan says have you used ionic with
react what do you think of it I've never
used ionic with react I did you see I
I've used ionic but it was probably like
I don't know six years ago
I hate ionic so I thought it was really
cool when I did use it I probably
wouldn't use it now ionic is a way to
build mobile apps with JavaScript so I
probably wouldn't use the ionic with
react if I wanted to build a mobile app
using react I would just use react
native so I don't know unless there's
some benefit to using ionic with react
that I don't know about that's which way
I would go if I if I wanted to use Java
some other JavaScript framework to build
a and a half then I probably would go
with ionic
alright I'm getting down towards the end
of the chat so
see trying to find the questions here
okay here's one why most of programmers
are arrogant I don't I don't know are
programmers arrogant maybe I don't I
don't really know any maybe that's a
psychology question that's not my my
area so I hope I don't come off as
arrogant if I do I apologize
there's some I saw a few questions about
people saying I just joined the stream
what are we doing
check out the recording and you know go
back to the beginning and then you'll
get a good explanation of what's what's
happening
the IT thinker says where are you
reading the questions from I'm just
reading them from the chat so I'm just
scrolling down through the chat log and
and reading the questions decoder says
hey I cannot find any of these questions
in this chat yeah maybe it was because I
was way back at the beginning of the jet
is it possible to convert angular to
react to developer okay so you mean like
you you're an angular developer and you
want to become a reactive over yeah I
mean that's definitely possible if the
question is is it possible to convert an
angular app to a react app then that
that would be pretty difficult you would
have to like basically rewrite it okay
and now the question is which is better
angular or react that it just entirely
depends it depends on what you're trying
to build what your team is good with or
what you're good with already so that's
that's a tough question to answer
without any other any other information
Abhishek says I'm not able to run C++ in
Windows 10 what should I do
I don't I don't have any experience with
trying to run C++ in Windows 10 so I
unfortunately I can't answer your
question yeah I don't I don't know the
last time I did anything with C++
I wasn't probably in 2009 yeah
try 2000 and no it was before that it
was probably 2005 so it's been quite a
while since I've done anything with C++
sorry I can't can't help with that how
many days to learn react uh I don't know
it depends on how much you already know
how many hours per day you can you can
dedicate to it
Jaeger says why is common jsn imports
intact in that file like both of them it
state truth I'm not entirely sure why
they're both in there I don't remember
if I did that or if that was some code I
copy and paste it in I don't know
Trung says can you teach us soft skills
I don't nobody in the stream but I guess
I could talk about soft skills maybe not
enough maybe that would be like better
for a video like on my channel I do more
like recorded video tutorials maybe that
would be good but it's hard to teach
like I can talk about it but teaching it
would probably take like a lot of
actually practice and experience and
stuff
Carlos says I just want to say thank you
for sharing your time and knowledge keep
up the good work
oh thanks I appreciate it and thanks for
watching
Abhishek says can you assure can you
talk about the stability of a job
without a degree yeah honestly I here's
the way I feel about job stability with
or without a degree it seems like at
least so I'm coming from the United
States I live near Pittsburgh in the
United States so it may not it's
probably different in other places but
it seems to me like like I personally
don't count on stability in my job so I
I'm always trying to be ready like try
to keep my resume my resume my LinkedIn
updated try to keep my skills updated
and because I don't count on always
being able to work at the same place
that I'm working so you have companies
like if you're at a small company small
company throughout a business or get
bought out like all the time right so
you're probably not gonna have much job
stability if you at a start-up or a
small company but even large companies
they they change things they restructure
they you know they fire employees things
change so frequently that I just think
it's better to assume that no matter
what you're probably not gonna have much
job stability right so my assumption for
myself is that I'll probably change jobs
every few years
and so I just try to keep myself
prepared for that
so just making sure that I keep track of
like what is the most in-demand
one of the most in-demand skills right
now what should I be learning like
trying to go to conferences and talk to
people like in terms of networking and
stuff so that's how I I feel I don't I
don't know that having a degree would it
like in the software engineering field
I don't know that having a degree would
make you have more or less job stability
in other fields like in general just in
life having a degree probably would help
you to get more jobs because there's
still a lot of jobs out there that they
just want a degree no matter what even
if it doesn't make sense for you to have
a degree but if you want to stick with
software engineering once you get to the
point where you have some job experience
the degree really doesn't matter that
much for most software engineering jobs
hopefully that answered your question
Danae says what is best between an
android app or single page app that that
really kind of depends like on what what
you're trying to do a single page app
would run in the browser obviously so
like an Android app is going to be a
mobile app for the phone so it it's I
don't know that it's a question of
what's the past in general it would be
like what would is the goal like what's
the what is the app which is supposed to
be doing what's the goal visit Joe says
what's the best place for finding a job
online for angular or react this is the
places that I like to go for finding a
job online so believe it or not Twitter
is a good place if you like let people
know on Twitter that you're looking I've
had a lot of a lot of good luck with
people contacting me about jobs on
Twitter LinkedIn there's a place was it
called zip recruiter zip recruiter I
like it because they show a lot of like
salary information which is good to know
like up front and then Stack Overflow
has a job site so those are probably the
places that I would recommend looking it
but that's coming from somebody in the
United States if you're in different
parts of the world I don't know how
helpful those places are there might be
other web sites that are better but
that's where I would I would check amir
says react native or flutter I haven't
used flutters so I don't really think I
could give a good comparison I do really
like react native
I've heard good things about flutter but
like I just I don't know enough about it
I think to really do a good job of
talking about why you would want to use
it or not use it
compared to react native JMO vlog says
what's your favorite coding language I
like JavaScript I mean it's it's what I
code with most often not that I don't
like other languages but if I had to
pick a favorite I'd probably say I was
good or do novel system can we watch a
recorded version of the session yep the
recording will be available probably
just a few minutes after I end this one
let's see
all right Abhishek says who gets more
salary a person with or without a degree
and this is from India so I to be honest
with you I don't know very much at all
about the job market in India so I don't
know that I can answer that question
so if there's anybody from India that
has any experience for that please you
know maybe throw an answer out here or
if you're watching the recording maybe
later on in the in the comments pat-pat
cell says great job how can I beg how
can I become a good programmer can I do
that by reading people's code
yeah reading other people's code
definitely helps give you more ideas
about how to do things but I would say
more than just reading it is like
actually working with it so like if you
see an open-source project like I think
it's even more helpful instead of just
reading it try to actually contribute to
it then you really start to understand
it like how it works and I think that
will help you to become a better
programmer because you'll hopefully pick
up on all the good ideas that other
programmers are having and like start
incorporating that into your project I
know like I worked on an open source
project recently I did some streams on
it on my youtube channel
it was the react native a sink storage
package and that package was using
typescript and so I had to learn
typescript to contribute and now I've
incorporated typescript into my other
projects so it's like I kind of absorbed
some of that and and just you know it's
made my code better by contributing to
this other project
let's see how to make sure I keep track
of time so I can work alright so we'll
do a few more questions
before I wrap this up let's see had a
job as a junior dev for eight months and
left on good terms
I know front end with UJS would you
learn back-end to go full stack or just
look for another front-end position
honestly like if I needed to find a job
I needed money I would just look for a
front-end position and like try to learn
as I go if like I really wanted to go
full stack and I didn't need a job right
away then yeah maybe learn learn
back-end but it so kind of depends on
your situation can you talk about coding
bootcamp thank you I have never done a
coding bootcamp so I don't know that
much about it my wife did do a coding
bootcamp and she loved it and she got a
job right away so she did the Flatiron
school boot camp so I think boot camps
can be really helpful but you got to
make sure you're going to a good boot
camp so do your research first and
probably like see you check out where
the people are working that have gone
through that boot camp right because
that's the proof of whether or not the
boot camp is going to get you ready for
a job like have people already gone
through this boot camp and gotten jobs
and don't just look at what the boot
camp says like look at their people who
have actually gone to the boot camp you
know and like maybe trying to reach out
to him on Twitter or something and say
like hey you did this boot camp like
what did you think of it
JMO vlog says where's the best place to
find conference talks networking
opportunities
you cannot so this might be a weird way
to look for conferences but if you go to
paper call dot IO you can search for
conferences and events and you can
search by keywords so you could type in
like JavaScript to react and you could
find a bunch of conferences and events
there I think it's just tech conferences
that they have on there so that might
not be a bad way to to check it out
Andre says I'm assuming this is the
question is do I really need to use
Redux and all react projects you
definitely don't need Redux in all your
react projects so I I rarely use Redux
in my react projects I only use Redux if
it gets to the point where it's really
the state management starts to get very
complex and I feel like it could be
helpful to use redux
let's see Xena says for half-hour I just
listened and watched lot of nothing
yeah the at the end of the stream we
just do question an answer so yes so if
the coding is the first part of the
stream second part is question and
answer
cyberworld astute when do you start your
coding coding is the first so like we're
done with coding at this point so Malik
says can you tell me the learning curve
to be a front-end dev for example HTML
CSS just like what yeah I don't know I
don't know exactly how to explain the
learning curve I guess but yeah like
that's that's the way you'd want to go
right like if you want to be a front-end
developer start with HTML CSS JavaScript
then maybe check out some sort of
framework like once you learn HTML CSS
and JavaScript I would like start
building stuff don't wait to actually
build stuff and then then you'll start
to get a feel for like oh you know I'm
doing this this thing over and over
again maybe there's some library that
does it for me right that's kind of like
I think you kind of naturally need to
branch out or want to branch out and
learn other libraries and things
okay
yes you know so I'm yeah I'm not gonna
cone anymore for this stream so like for
the first hour we code and then after
that we do Question and Answer
alright alright last question and then
we'll be done this is why react and not
view I work with react I know react I
don't know of you I mean that's really
it like so I work with react at my job
and I've been working with react for a
while so that's when I'm good with so
that's what I'm gonna work with you use
a good framework as well I haven't done
anything with it but I've heard good
things about it so but yeah that's why
we're doing weirdo react stuff you
wouldn't want to watch me do a view
stream because I'm no good with you I
don't know anything about it alright so
anyway thank you so much for watching
I'm gonna try to stream more regularly
now and get back into it and yes so let
me put this today Friday yeah so have a
great weekend hopefully I'll stream
again next week and yeah if you want I
don't know if I have this up on github
her yet yet or not I was gonna say if
anybody wants to try to like load this
and work on these bugs feel free but I'm
not sure if I have this up on github if
I do have it up on get up the link will
be in the description
if not I'll try to get it up there throw
the link in the description at some
point soon so anyway until next time
have a great weekend thank you so much
for watching